it's been six long years since our last
motorcycle ride down the highways of
inland california with jax teller
played by charlie hunnam and the rest of
the sons of anarchy motorcycle club
redwood original charter
the spin-off series mayans mc has been
fun but nothing can really replace that
sons of anarchy-sized hole in our
television lives
it's a counterintuitive vice of living
in the era of peak tv that the plethora
of fresh options available
only makes us lament the loss of our
favorites even more right about now
fans appear to be at the absolute
pinnacle of their power to reanimate
their favorite series
at least were cult classics cancelled
before their time are concerned
even if an all-new season of sons of
anarchy feels like a reach is it really
too much to hope the cast might dig
their leather cuts out of the closet and
reunite for a quick special
that kind of fan service never hurt
anybody as might be expected hanum and
the rest of the series's gifted stars
regularly have to field eager questions
about the possibility of a reunion so
what's the latest
people magazine got the scoop but
spoiler alert it's not promising
clearly it's no fun to dash fans hopes
and dreams most actors hammond hall when
faced with a question like this well
some actually do express unadulterated
enthusiasm for the reunion proposition
but not
charlie hunnam sure it's great to have
steady work in showbiz and sons of
anarchy is undoubtedly one of this
generation's great shows but inhabiting
a character as dark and tragic as
jackson teller has to take a toll
fans learned after the series concluded
that hanum takes his performances very
seriously
he even went an entire year of filming
without speaking to co-star ron perlman
just to cultivate the kind of on-screen
loathing he needed on camera
the two ultimately made up after the
series concluded and hanham confessed
his method to perlman
hanum told people it was a very deep
experience i lived with that character
inside me for years like
in a very real way in a way that
manifested in ways that i could never
even imagine
i would never ever put that cut back on
i would never put his rings back on not
even for halloween
no one will ever put that cut on again
like that we gotta respect
that dude as jax confesses in his final
moments on sons of anarchy he is not a
good man
becoming that no good very bad man and
living in his skin for so many years
must have been a challenge for hunnam so
it's hard to really blame him for
wanting to move on
it's certainly easy to understand why
jax might be a troubling character to
inhabit for so long but there's another
reason hana may not see the need to
return to the role
his ending on sons of anarchy was pretty
well definitive
the finale of the long running series
doesn't leave much wiggle room for jax
to return and it's not exactly a happy
ending as hunnam pointed out
he's dead now so there would be no ever
bringing him back when he died he died
as creator kurt sutter is explained many
times sons of anarchy is an updated take
on shakespeare's
hamlet gemma is gertrude clay morrow is
the usurping king claudius
some combination of wendy and terra
stands in for ophelia and hanum's jax
teller is the morality plays indecisive
prince
as those viewers out there who aren't
total philistines already know from the
series outset
hamlet doesn't exactly make it and
despite steve coogan's best efforts
there is no hamlet too
father i forgive you i forgive you
i forgive you by the time sons of
anarchy reaches the end of its final act
most of its principles are gone
as is the case with its elizabethan
source material hunnam is a classically
trained actor no doubt familiar with the
inner workings of the play
and he knows as well as anyone that some
characters are best left in the ground
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one